ah so you bring them out in front
and we had the Palms down on the throw
this time
so we had the Palms up this time the
Palms down take around
right so we've got several pieces here
that are all the same so that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to get
our body used to the same pieces
so
ah
it's like cutting down
you step through you turn
but you're about to dip backwards so
that means that this
has to fold in the middle the same as
you share a moment ago
here you're going to have to fold in the
middle
please talk in Japan what they what they
think or they go Banzai right Banzai
it's it's like when they drink
okay it's like
what do you say here Cheers Cheers they
go bonsai
because they're happy so you can use
this uh Michael
you can use this feeling in this the
seniors have to learn how to be sensible
so they have to do it with uh
see this is your spirit coming out so
this is the same as key eye you go
Banzai
then you've got real power
now the seniors they're doing something
like this
because they think they've got tough
arms
so they go they take it down and they
and their next rather
but if you have the spirit
[Music]
you'll do it better and when you become
adults you'll know that it's
up
like this
down
turn so
okay
so this word's Banzai
and the arms down cut through
okay you if you get it perhaps adults or
copy don't worry that's what you shall
be doing
foreign